im phoenix studio in bonn begrüße ich
jetzt joachim weber er ist
sicherheitsexperte
politikwissenschaftler und historiker
herzlich willkommen bei phoenix sie
haben den kanzler gerade
gehört was macht er da mit dieser
äußerungen stellt er deutschland die
bürger bereitet er sie auf einen
längeren krieg vor oder wie würden sie
das interpretieren als ich glaube er hat
sehr passende worte gefunden die
situation die lage ist dramatisch und
sie eskaliert natürlich weiter
eskaliert weiter dadurch dass russland
jetzt die zweite staffel seiner angriffs
kräfte da in die schlacht wirft und
möglicherweise ist die erste staffel die
schwächere gewesen vielleicht auch mit
dem schlechteren gerät noch ausgestattet
gewesen jetzt kommt der zweite versuch
möglicherweise wird auch eine dritte
staffel dahinter vom firmiert falls die
zweite nicht reichen sollte also die
russen erhöhen definitiv den
militärischen druck und das bringt
natürlich per se eine erhebliche
intensivierung der gesamten situation
eine eine verschlechterung mit sich es
ist ganz furchtbar aber wir müssen jetzt
über waffensysteme sprechen herr weber
da gibt es zwei systeme die jetzt immer
wieder genannt werden das eine sind
thermo bahre sprengköpfe die jetzt
offenbar er wird schon eingesetzt worden
sind oder die vorbereitet werden für den
einsatz was sind thermo bahre
sprengköpfe das ist wirklich etwas etwas
fürchterliches und ich glaube auch die
russischen streitkräfte das russische
her sind die einzigen streitkräfte
weltweit die die in dieser form zur
verfügung haben das sind so eine art
flammen bomben die werden also mit einer
begrenzten reichweite gegen die wand
geschleudert und und haben dort eine
verpuffung an der verbrennung die die
luft so erhitzt dass in einer fläche die
damit abgedeckt wird wirklich
buchstäblich alles verbrennt da können
sie auch im schützengraben sitzen die
die luft fängt an zu blühen und zu
brennen das ist schrecklich weil so eine
zweite fürchterliche sache
ist offenbar
mehrfach raketenwerfer system die werden
jetzt auch dorthin gebracht vor allem
richtung kiew was ist das ja das ist im
kern nichts neues das ist im grunde die
stalin orgel die seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg kennen als die russen dieses
ding erfunden haben nicht das sind also
raketenwerfer die große salven von
raketen schießen und auch diese waffe
richtet sich gegen flächen ziele wie man
das mit herrischen sprach gewordenen die
man sonst nicht greifen kann das sind
keine waffen die auf den punkt ziehen um
ein geschütz oder im panzer zu zerstören
oder ein haus zu treffen wo sich jemand
verschanzt hat sondern die wollen
einfach flächenhaft totmachen nicht
unten dafür sind diese dinge leider sehr
wirkungsvoll herr kollege vorhin von
ihnen also ein sicherheitsexperte hat
davon gesprochen dass jetzt die methode
aleppo und großen quasi zur anwendung
kommt also syrien respektive
tschetschenien was ist damit gemeint was
ist das für eine strategie ja
wahrscheinlich ist das so wäre der erste
russische angriff glatt durchgeschlagen
man hätte das regierungsviertel erobert
und aus russischer sicht wäre alles gut
gewesen wäre es dazu wahrscheinlich
nicht gekommen aber dadurch dass der
russische vormarsch stockt und die
ukraine sich wie die löwen verteidigen
und die russen nicht vorankommen werden
sie in der folge immer mehr schießt zeug
nachziehen und da die ukraine ein
offener feldschlacht sich in der fläche
des landes kaum behaupten können gegen
die luftüberlegenheit der osten die
athletische überlegenheit ziehen sie
sich natürlich immer weiter zurück
werden zurückgedrängt auf die städte und
wenn man dann eigene opfer vermeiden
will wenn man jetzt mit infanterie da
reingeht die werden eins zu eins
sozusagen tod geschossen das wollen die
russen wahrscheinlich auch vermeiden das
heißt sie holen sie holen artillerie
mehrfach raketen mehr voran und und
pulverisieren alles was sich in den weg
stellt das ist in der tat die methode
großen die da wird auf zivilisten und
gar nichts rücksicht genommen sondern in
schutt und asche gelegt was können die
ukrainer in dieser jetzigen situation
tun welche waffensysteme
wären oder sind jetzt notwendig um sich
dagegen zur wehr zu setzen auf gut
deutsch gesagt alle alles was man hat
nicht womit man hier schießen kann es
ist ein ungleicher kampf in wenn der
gegner die lufthoheit hat oder die
totale luft herrschaft ausübt dann hat
man schon
sehr viel schlechtere karten sich zu
behaupten auf dauer man kann keine
athletin vorstellung irgendwo auffahren
die werden erkannt die werden in
kürzester zeit zerschlagen sei es durch
beschuss mit mehrfach raketenwerfern
oder durch luftangriffe durch
raketenangriffe im grunde bleibt in
ukraine ab irgendeinem zeitpunkt nur
noch die möglichkeit sich in die städte
zurück zu ziehen und aus jedem fenster
zu schießen aber die folge ist natürlich
auch das was wir soeben besprochen haben
ja das war präsident selensky vor rund
anderthalb stunden mit einem wirklich
dramatischen appell mit dieser rede live
zugeschaltet aus kiew ins eu-parlament
herüber selensky bittet ja ganz
dramatisch auf ganz dramatische art und
weise die eu um aufnahme und um hilfe
weil wir vielleicht mit dem zweiten ass
kann außer humanitäre hilfe zu leisten
die eu in dieser jetzigen situation wo
sich die militärische lage in der
ukraine verschärft jetzt noch leisten
das ist eine ungeheuer schwierige frage
die eu kann die ukraine politisch
unterstützen sie kann sie wirtschaftlich
unterstützen sie kann sie in maßen
militärisch unterstützen und ich betone
in maßen denn wir müssen aufpassen dass
wir trotz sicherlich berechtigter
maßnahmen wie die lieferung zum beispiel
von defensiv waffen wie panzerfäuste und
wie auch diese dinger flieger zu paketen
dass wir aber auch nicht eine grenze
überschreiten also in dem moment wo die
eu oder vielleicht auch die nato beginnt
sozusagen die logistik für die
ukrainische armee bereitzustellen
laufen wir gefahr in über eine linie zu
rutschen eine linie die eine bahn die
abschüssig ist eine bahn die uns auch in
die situation bringen kann dass wir auf
einmal der russischen föderation und
ihren streitkräften als aktive gegner
gegenüberstehen also ich warne auch
ausdrücklich jetzt davor ist zu weit zu
treiben ist ja nicht die nato sondern im
moment gibt es offenbar einzelne
eu-länder die
trotz der großen bedrohung durch die
russen oder vielleicht sollte man sagen
wegen der großen bedrohung durch die
russen offenbar bereit sind ja auch
flugzeuge zu liefern da ist die rede
hier von polen der slowakei und
bulgarien die wohl insgesamt 70
flugzeuge unter anderem vom typ mig 29
bereit sein zu liefern die werden dann
abgeholt in polen von ukrainischen
piloten die offenbar in der lage sind
diese maschinen zu bedienen was meinen
sie wer da so ein punkt über den man
jetzt nicht hinausgehen sollte oder ist
es schon so ein kritischer punkt wo der
diktator im kreml anfängt zu zucken wir
sind da sicherlich langsam an einem
kritischen punkt dran und ich verstehe
ja diese maßnahmen wie wir sind ja
sozusagen im herzen jetzt alle ukraine
wir wir erleben dass sein land mitten in
europa auf brutalste weise angegriffen
wird wie wir ertragen dass kaum was wir
da sehen müssen und und und dennoch es
gibt eine zweite ebene neben der
berechtigten absicht und der
notwendigkeit der ukrainer sich zu
verteidigen aber wir können auch nicht
da rein schlittern dass diese geschichte
aus dem ruder läuft nicht also aus dem
ruder laufen entschuldung der wahl heißt
ja immer die das sozusagen die atomare
bedrohung im hintergrund mit dabei ist
also es gibt taktische atomwaffen habe
ich gestern gelernt sind atomwaffen die
lokal begrenzt wirken sollen oder
eingesetzt werden werden das ist teil
der russischen militärdoktrin der westen
setzt atombomben nur ein und damit zu
drohen damit es nicht zum einsatz kommt
ich glaube das sind ja wohl die großen
unterschiede jetzt spielen wir das mal
weiter wie sehr sind wir denn geschützt
oder wie sehr sind wir eben nicht
geschützt vor möglichen angriffen aus
kaliningrad richtung berlin
beispielsweise naja ich bin noch lange
nicht beim atomkrieg aber wir laufen
gefahr einfach in eine
eskalationsspirale zu landen nicht in
dem moment wo es den russen sozusagen so
viel zu viel wird mit der unterstützung
der ukraine mit den torhütern laufen wir
gefahr dass sie in irgendeiner weise
weiter eskalieren und es kann sich
aufschaukeln aldi atomwaffen sind noch
weit weg kaliningrad ja was soll man
dazu sagen dass der fluch der bösen tat
dass man nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
dieses territorium das frühere nördliche
ostpreußen ja aber den russen hat landen
lassen und damit haben sie hat diese
militär colonia begründet die natürlich
nach allen richtungen jedermann bedroht
sozusagen einen ein hunderte von
kilometern vorgeschobener flugzeugträger
nicht auf dem jede menge raketenwaffen
anderes stationiert sind oder haben wir
einen schutz davor also jetzt mal ganz
dezidiert gemeint in deutschland haben
einen schutz davor naja was da an waffen
stationiert es reicht nicht
wahrscheinlich direkt bis deutschland
kann man darüber streiten wie weit die
raketen doch weiterreichen dass das
wissen vielleicht die geheimdienste
genauer das ist ja der streit um diese
iskander raketen zum beispiel gewesen
deswegen ja auch der der vertrag dann
gegründet
gekündigt wurde also einer der gründe
jedenfalls dafür gut ist das nicht aber
wir sind neben kriegen russland das muss
noch mal betont werde die ukraine ist im
krieg mit russland und wir sollten alles
daran setzen dass die nato und die eu
sie haben gefragt nach der eu und gesagt
dass nicht die nato ich glaube mit
diesen differenzierungen gibt man sich
immer hält man sich in russland nicht
allzu lange mehr auf wie die russen ist
dass der westen und da wird man nicht
übermäßig differenzieren ob jetzt
frankreich was mitglied der us und der
nato oder deutschland dieses und jenes
macht sondern es ist der westmann hat
sich verrannt man sieht sich als
russland sozusagen unter dem druck des
westens und dieser druck
schmerz die russen weil sie ihre
politischen ziele nicht erreichen da
ärgert sie massiv und ich mache mir
zunehmend sorgen dafür oder darüber dass
wir jetzt nur noch über über die abwehr
dieser aggression reden dass sie alles
berechtigt die ukraine sterben jeden tag
natürlich stellen sie diese frage und
stellen sie auch an uns aber wir müssen
uns auch über den übergeordneten
gedanken machen und für mich wird es
immer dringlicher sich zu überlegen wie
können wir herrn putin der sich völlig
verrannt hat er auch viel kalkuliert hat
wie können wir ihn dennoch wieder
rausholen wer baut ihm die brücke zu
einer politischen lösung
militärisch wird am ende wenn er die
will aber er hat er hat bestimmte
politische ziele die erreicht da jetzt
nicht er merkt ja dass das nicht so
läuft wie er sich das vorgestellt er
beantwortet das mit noch mehr militär
noch mehr schießen noch mehr brutalität
das bringt eskalation rein und wo
eskalationsspirale enden wissen wir
nicht